venons en maintenant à la politique un
mois après l'échec des européennes les
dirigeants du modem se sont réunis à
huis clos aujourd'hui à paris ces
dernières semaines des élus des
militants avaient dénoncé une gestion
trop personnelle du mouvement sans pour
autant remettre en cause directement la
place de françois bayrou
un congrès est prévu à l'automne pour
déterminer la ligne politique en vue des
régionales de 2010 les réactions
recueillies par bénédicte doré et robin
teboul derrière l'interdiction entré le
premier conseil national un mois et demi
après la défaite aux européennes
les militants étaient réunis à huis clos
et il avait beaucoup de choses à dire
les militants les sympathisants les
proches du conseil national ont dit ce
qu'ils avaient sur le coeur ce qui est
tout à fait extrêmement utile
quelques semaines après c'est bien
d'ailleurs c'est à dire c'est pas à vif
c'est bien et prêt on voit maintenant
comment on prépare la rentrée politique
sur les universités d'été du modem à
grande mode début septembre
et comment on fait pour résister
fortement dans la vie politique et
française bien sûr ils sont revenus sur
les chèques
françois bayrou jure en avoir tiré les
leçons désormais il faut tourner la page
on a le son principal que j'ai retiré de
ces éléments c'est que au fond les les
français souhaite que nous soyons au
dessus de la mêlée pas dans le mail et
pour affronter l'avenir et les
prochaines échéances les militants ont
demandé un changement d'organisation du
parti christophe ginisty conseiller
national a écrit avec 300 adhérents une
lettre ouverte au leader du modem dans
laquelle il réclame l'élargissement du
bureau national et la nomination de
porte parole promis ce sera chose faite
dès la semaine prochaine
corinne lepage une des plus virulentes
après les européennes
et maintenant satisfaites alors oui je
suis content de la manière dont les
choses se sont passées ce matin oui et
je ne regrette pas ce que j'ai fait et
je ne regrette pas toute l'effervescence
qui a eu dans notre mouvement
qui lui a donné un vrai dynamisme pas un
mot sur les possibles alliances avec le
ps ou europe écologie mais la décision
d'une stratégie nationale pour les
régionales de l'an prochain
cet automne il y aura même un grand
congrès pour élaborer le programme ce
matin le jeune modem a décidé de grandir
alors avec nous sur le plateau de sault
retrouve à corinne lepage bonsoir vous
députée européene vice présidente du
modem bénédicte laure et le disais tout
à l'heure vous aviez été l'une des plus
virulentes au soir des européennes pour
dénoncer l'échec pas virulente mais très
active dans la demande de changement oui
dur et aujourd'hui vous dites
satisfaites de ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui est ce que vous êtes sûr que
ça va changer
écoutez il ya des engagements très
précis qui ont été pris sur la base du
travail qui a été fait par christophe
ginisty par les modems de l'étranger par
toute une série de gens qui ont
travaillé beaucoup de d'engagement été
pris par françois bayrou maintenant bien
entendu il faut que nous entrions dans
la réalisation de ses engagements
il faut que françois bayrou change aussi
françois bayrou change mais que le mode
de fonctionnement du modem change
on a cherché françois bayrou et françois
bayrou pour l'instant et ébène modem je
crois que tout le monde a compris
maintenant que c'est un vrai parti
politique on h 10 que ce qui était
important c'est d'être le meilleur
opposant
moi je crois que ce qui est important
c'est d'avoir le meilleur projet et
c'est là dessus que je veux me battre
alors françois bayrou indiqué
aujourd'hui que pour les élections
régionales il y aurait une ligne
politique qui s'appliquerait partout en
france sans en dire plus alors pour vous
est ce que le modem doit partir seul ou
est-ce qu'il doit déjà évoquer des
alliances possibles
ça va être tout l'objet de notre débat
qui va être un débat totalement
démocratique puisque françois bayrou a
annoncé que nos candidats seraient
également élus par la base
tout au moins que nous allions voir
comment nous pouvions le mettre en place
cela fait partie de la réflexion sur le
projet mais personnellement le congrès
de cap 21 qui s'est réuni il ya quinze
jours a souhaité que si des alliances
était envisagé l'idée d'une alliance
avec europe écologie pas avec les verts
c'est à dire que le rassemblement europe
écologie puisse être privilégiés encore
bien entendu
faudra-t-il que ce soit un choix du made
m voilà est-ce que vous êtes sur des
suivis là dessus je suis pas sûr d'être
suivi mais nous sommes dans un système
démocratique
nous allons discuter ici régional pour
le modem ce sera un test peut-être la
dernière chance aussi en politique vous
savez comme moi qui a pas de dernière
chance mais c'est important que nous
réussissions et je crois que chacun peut
juger que en application de l'adage
selon lequel tout ce qui ne nous tue pas
rend plus fort et bien le modem sans
renforcé de cette affaire alors on
l'évoqué à l'instant les écologistes eux
sortent toujours sur leur succès des
européennes qui leur donne des envie
d'autonomie à eux aussi pour les
élections régionales de 2010 il
organisait aujourd'hui l'écologie day à
saint-ouen en seine-saint-denis une
façon de déjà lancé la campagne daniel
cohn bendit appelle les verts à ne pas
engager d'accord tout de suite avec le
ps met à discuter avec l'ensemble de la
gauche
jusqu'au modem et il souhaite qu'europe
écologie devienne le rassemblement de
tous les écologistes
au delà des seuls verts et donc corinne
lepage il s'adresse à vous aussi
est-ce que vous acceptez cette
proposition vous avez dit chaleur ok
pour travailler avec europe écologie ni
europe écologie eux ils veulent bien
travaille aussi avec le ps le pc expert
est-ce que c'est jouable ça moi je suis
modem j'y suis bien
je souhaite que le modem soit un parti
qui soutiennent le développement
soutenable
je suis intéressé parce que ce que dit
daniel cohn bendit je l' ai entendu je
suis pas du tout persuadé que les verts
marche dans sept grandes orientations
l'a donc pour le moment nous travaillons
chez nous j'attends de voir un peu la
manière dont europe écologie va évoluer
et puis peut-être nous pourrons parler
de d'alliance futur c'est pas et c'est
pas inenvisageable
mais il faut attendre pour l'instant
dernière question le débat sur
l'instauration de la taxe carbone
on en saura un peu plus la semaine
prochaine elle permettrait de fixer une
taxe sur les industries polluantes qui
serait reversé pour récompenser ceux qui
polluent moins
est ce que ça ne risque pas d'être une
usine à gaz tout simplement écouter il
ya des pays qu'ils font la suède avec
beaucoup de succès donc il faut faire un
système qui soit simple qui soit
incitatif et qui permettent surtout et
c'est le plus important de développer
une vraie industrie française de
l'efficacité énergétique et du
renouvelable
c'est à cela que ça doit servir quand
une page merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce soir